es gibt noch ein stockwerk könnte man
denken wenn ich mal freude der besucher
habe ich die sache kommt rein ich zeige
euch heute mal meine neue wohnung
normalerweise bin ich ein sprecher
karsais regierung den wegen auf oder
irgendwas richtig einzuordnen ist aber
erstmal schön geworden dass ich mir mit
einfach nicht bei mir etwa an mit meinen
schlaf dem ok gibt einmal weg rein der
stadt marl ich meine wohnung mannschaft
immer in meinen normalen einfach hier
[Musik]
eine zweite finke hat offen bemerkt hier
der badewanne ist aber als designer die
neben recht bescheid
wir geben einen punkt gemacht
[Musik]
ein fernseher
da merke ich wenn ich eine pizza zu
besuch da habe auch den entsprechenden
grünen machen kann zum beispiel hallo
also kleiner pisser das tier wieder
zentren am sonntag ist die kleine aber
bescheiden
[Musik]
hier bietet auch meine monaten ihr
verfrüht comeback gibt jetzt viel besser
auch wenn ich über und bleibe
möglichkeiten hier ist alles echt
gemacht und die deutsche welle hat er
möchte darauf vorbereitet sein dass ja
immer wieder kenne genug hat sich auch
hier ein frühlingslied keine das
begriffen die noch keine dokumenten wird
die strecke hinab werden gern spanisch
und hochwertiger keine ganze sache mit
ihren bescheid und wird mir leid
erinnert gerne hilfe die mit übelkeit
weil man hier einsätze kommt nicola
daran
es hat einen ganz besonderen feier ich
wär natürlich auch hier wieder kleiner
stream um die partie doch unbedingt
gabriel bebaut ist abgeschlossen die
draußen und therapiert hier haben wir
die kleine kiste macht ja mal aufstellen
ich meine hier kann man einfach locken
er schwärmte werde richtig gesagt klar
kann man auch hier mit dem einladenden
verfügen wir auch im kanton neuerung
kommt manchmal wenn ihr langweilig ist
wirklich einfach hier oben drauf fällen
ist der kölner john tripp ist das
vergnügen das dach schacht dann nicht so
gute freunde von mir einfach gelaufen da
aufgebaut wird einige überhaupt
niemanden dem maxplatz sehr gut dank
haben wir noch mal die zweite kasse ja
keiner bescheid da halt irgendwann mal
was liegen nicht von michael weber danke
ich werde heute dürfen den
vielsprachigkeit wird irgendeine
parlament in diesem video clique denke
das ist für eine geburt ihrer freundin
wurde eingeleitet
so ziemlich auf die cad-software schüler
aber da wird das zu fangen ich bin auch
viel nochmal die gleiche ausstattung und
wer keine bessere
ihr könnt mir bekannt ist macht vor
kurzem nach köln geflogen und ich dachte
einfach jetzt angebot für die wohnung
bekommen und ich dachte mir man muss ja
nur ab wenn man wirklich lange und hart
gearbeitet um mich jahre
dabei gegeben hatten einfach wie ein
richtiger vollidioten vor der kamera
verstehen dann kann man die arbeiten
[Musik]
weder die fed cup eine gute winzig leben
halt wirklich bescheid leute dann gibt
aber hier nochmal unterhalten und die
besenkammer sollten wir dafür einfach
wenn man der umwelt in engen räumen für
aufregen kann einem durchaus ein
beklemmendes gefühl bekommen deswegen
habe ich hier unten auf den relax klein
aber besteigen
jeder sein kann man zum beispiel einfach
hier drüber und ich dann hier auch mit
mehreren freunden film reinziehen zb b
movie oder motiven heraus kommt versteht
was ich meine
da gibt's selbstverständlich damit man
nicht versucht wird dabei ein paar
getränke
doch welche das klingt einfach klingt
einfach keine alkohol völkerschlacht
dann haben wir auch noch solche sachen
hier ist es wie butler das ist ein
smartphone technologie das heißt sie
einfach so langweilig wird alle vorhänge
in der wohnung steuern ich kann alle
lichter steuern
ich kann die heizung star wars also
wirklich langweilige und bewerten
johnson betonte weiter dass man kein
erfolgreicher steigen meinte die dritte
gescheiterte meine dusche für die drei
monitore kann mich einfach wenn ich dann
noch jungen in die play offs machte und
in barth 1 durch die medien bei flat und
die technik einfach und alle weder
benutzen oder auch wenn ihr denkt auch
mal neue räume in der wohnung der ferne
überwachen spielt damit ich beim
zähneputzen wird oder vielleicht auch
weltkrieg darunter kommt heute kann man
ja auch noch ein hobby wird larry
mitchell der kamera bildschirm machte
mit dem 3
einige minuten später krachte die
kameras zeigen so die kräfte aufpassen
wenn ihr auch kleine grüne hat wirklich
auch in baden durch schleifen und
feierte am ende dabei alles klappt werde
ich euch für zustand beim einer kleinen
aber bescheidenen raum tour
die botschaft die ich ruhe bringen
möchte ist einfach bleibt bodenständig
gleichzeitig unterbringen möchte ist
seit einfach keine hohen sich nicht
gemacht denn ich hab ich auch genommen
wie du dich jetzt gewählt nicht richtig
fett und ich selbst vorher noch nie
gesehen älter aber leider haben wir
heute hier nur gedreht den ganzen tag
deswegen sind wir auch hier noch mit
zugangs dass kein vettel wäre - aber es
kommt in zukunft auch noch videos aus
dieser bude auf die matte steht kanal
glaubt mir das wird uns mal hochgenommen
mehr schöne bundes gesehen daumen nach
oben zeigte